hello family
I'm Greg this is Ashley men is
Morgenthau tears of Morgan and Ashley
that's their YouTube channel how she
blogs make a right is their Instagram
make sure to go follow them hey people
let me happy happy to in recently run a
patreon and one of the rewards if you
contributed a certain amount whatever
video you request we will definitely
watch this channel we primarily only do
videos that have multiple requests but
this one slowly requested by spring let
me just zoom in on her face here so you
guys can see is a hot girl sexy sexy my
name on this video game Halo with
killing spree to know the like after you
killed me feel the like cool is buried
yeah I subscribed a few years ago when I
saw her to this day reaction like shame
coins and to keep it to keep it kind of
bittersweet could you react to his phone
instruction for a bad day it's a very
moving poem that have got me through a
lot I know you would appreciate it
thanks are you ready ladies
yeah I could use some instructions for a
bad day yeah God knows you can we all
can get exhauster e that will be bad
days
[Music]
because
loosen your grip OPH calm slowly now let
go
go meditation no the town is only a
moment
today nation teaches in the channel over
drone backless unless you cannot escape
me diligence click the grey sky to
realize that read are clouding the to
the truth and the truth is let me see
that we're not that a sly thing to say
without remorseful complexity a man
music
here we go
under gun
this is equality
[Music]
I'm cool
now
Oh
but we can teach you this is the burden
maintaining giving your focus to wrath
will leave your entire self absent what
you need is love and hate are beasts and
the woman that grows is the one who PS
these are we growing to attract them is
immense
no it's not supposed to go there
resolute declare what is true
we consider in
everything you can
time delays on
[Music]
Oh
right
press yourself
okay
[Music]
equation not
[Music]
that what people wandering out
every halogen
only way we know how to say become
loosen your grip poking each palm slowly
now let go we're gonna try the girl from
13 reasons why I should have listened to
that the show yeah there we know Sheldon
that was very beautiful don't let a lot
in there a lot of good lines yeah I like
the before you about the quit it
continuous absolutely a lot of this
stuff to make a for life going into
specific lyrics I really do love the
message of this because over the years
without going into too much personal
life stuff over the years with a lot of
like personal development audio books
and books and seminar stuff and then
therapy learning to apply positivity but
also learn and face my emotions like a
constant balance I like how how he's
talking about that here how and order
let go you do sort of have to get to
feel it and accept it and be honest
about it like the process of pain is
interesting because you have to you have
to sort of sit with it feel it allow it
so that way it starts letting go and
then you can start applying positive
things on top again instead of taking
positivity and try to block the negative
stuff it's like I like how that comes
talking about feeling at all and I'm
applying new things as well or to keep
on moving yes and also where it sounds
like that you have to come with the
wonder you said oh Ashley where it says
like to not say like oh my I'm alright
like it's okay to not be alright
should I do that I'm only but not apply
online it was like internally like I'm
really like sad oh you need so I liked
it or like just just embraced button
okay if you're not so a to not be okay
yeah yeah I'll just I have a few
all-time sound like
okay now you better not be you okay yeah
I feel like when most people say I'm
okay that you leaving something's wrong
and you know I'm fine I'm fine I'm sorry
I'm just tired you know and we'll
sleeping what about you Morgan I'm so
quiet that you still is living and
sinking in no could like I mean clay
explicit I'm reflecting know what like
you said great like over the years and
through times we have had some craft
stuff like this helps affirmations and
positivity and like meditating and
things like that and knowing that like
honestly as terrible as you feel like it
does get better even when you really
feel like you're like I I won't make it
past this moment I won't make it past a
second because I ain't no idea everybody
has been there to the point where they
really really feel like that and it's
just we don't even know you have it
anyway you do yeah like the line in
there I think he says nightmares have a
beginning but bad days have an end yeah
yeah and you have to remember you have
to remember that and sometimes we get so
caught up in it that like you can't calm
yourself down and things like this just
explode out and breathe and just know
that like all right it's going to suck
yeah while and or ever however I can
help any of that you know I feel like
yeah that sucks and it is what it is but
it's going to get better as opposed to
like you said trying to like okay yeah
positive you have you got me at first I
recommend you there David like if you
acknowledge how you're feeling it
actually gives it less power like if you
draw about it out loud it has less
control over you cuz you're
acknowledging and the more that you talk
about the better it gets
yeah exactly yeah cuz if you're if you
it just grows inside your mat in a
general way they could come out by
actions you take or thoughts you start
having if you're really impressing
something then like the farmer they said
like every everybody is not been through
what you're going you're but something
kind of like that which they feel I
don't think that no one's going to yeah
yeah we just felt like maybe on a
different level but like still relatable
yeah I feel like when you're honest with
people that usually opens up a door for
the other person to be honest as well I
don't really like to give advice right
away if someone's opening up to me about
something I my my goal is does this help
them feel understood primarily because I
feel were mainly looking for you're
looking for like understanding and
validation and like yeah I'm not feeling
something that you want to be heard yeah
suppose the time like advice we kind of
know the advice already like if we can
just let it out then we can start
applying the things we already know how
to snap out of it and get back to doing
what you got to do okay so the line here
like this one yeah realize every dark
cloud is a smoke screen and to blindness
from the truth and the truth is whether
we see them or not just from that
portion right there I really like that
line because whatever the truth is to us
what we perceive to be the truth yeah
yeah it's like what we perceive to be
good and bad there's no there's really
no such thing we've sort of just decided
as society what is good and what is bad
I go to the line katene the Sun and the
moon are still there and always there is
life and I really believe that in the
grey of things yeah that's why I love
this funk it's about accepting at all
not just it's only positivity only
positivity only darkness only darkness
like now you gotta learn to have both in
your life and no one to accept it's like
that movie with the five personalities
split identity no no that's I doubt like
the hominid enemy was that you have been
a good to live with sadness because it
you know yeah I first met you are and I
kind of never have her me sad yeah you
place the hours we're about fragments
yeah I go so like it to be you know to
feel the sadness is also you know very
important for a human being to also
appreciate the happiness as well you
know it reminds me I got to that movie
I'm um it reminds me of I think that
untethered soul is what I read and it's
basically about how like they say - like
acknowledge your pain because otherwise
like and you're like chakra levels or
whatever like it build and build and
buildings or all of this stuff until you
just feel terrible and you have all the
emotional scarring you because you
wouldn't acknowledge it like you were
hurt in the first place exactly and then
it just it creates a cycle so that every
time someone says something you they
first do it 20 times worse than it would
be if it if you dull bit what yeah many
times
I'm reading a book right now like I
reach page 80 yesterday yeah the mindful
past is self compassion a lot of the
book is such as what I've read so far
may God bless you in the middle of you
interrupting losses right on the good
point
sorry having a rather genuine sincere
conversation gossiper okay no no nice
swim in a really good point okay okay
sorry she's sorry I'm sorry I should
actually variance even caring person
yeah she is deep camera more so I
discover her emotions before working on
but margins are really working to
actually ride amen I really do she's
like all right I'm like you're not yeah
miss dawn cry girl cry oh I like the
ammunition line oh yeah oh yeah read it
Ashley life is going to come at you
armed with hard times and tough choices
your voice is your weapon your sucks
yeah there are no free extra men man
it's such a powerful poem your voice is
your weapon your thoughts ammunition I
was having a conversation my best bud
yesterday talking about any success
we've ever had or whatever troubles were
going through and then how to obtain
more and it really is just a mental game
like any level of success anyone has in
any department whether it just be
happiest or financial it's all about the
way you yeah starts with your thoughts
and your feelings and your actions can
destroy you or you know the power of
your success that human a it's so funny
how it's easier to go negative sometimes
oh yeah what at par to be like oh this
is great this is awesome like focus on
abundance and when you're like but one
thing one thing you're like I feel like
a lot of the times people will say don't
feel that way or don't think that way or
you especially hate it when someone says
to me like you shouldn't feel that way
yeah I shouldn't think that way yeah
there are emotions yeah exactly
I don't I don't feel like there isn't
any other there's the sugar students are
not really part of my vocabulary
because I feel like you know even if you
have to get positive sometimes it's like
if you want to get there you got to
start feeling really processing what the
hell going on with you currently and
then you can start applying these things
be the weed growing through the cracks
in this cement Oh beautiful I love it I
lined with it the guidance speaking I'm
a very soothing time especially going
yeah I thought we're looking to meditate
I enjoyed a meditation yeah yeah
smiles be the first aid kit that someone
in the money park what yeah and then
it's like it's funny cuz I hear
sometimes I like you'll be on the road
or like in line or whatever people are
like so angry you were never you get
like so offended it's like you don't
know what they're going through other
day yeah sure on them yeah I'm just like
the understanding like not getting mean
you know back again and you don't know
what's going on personally in their life
absolutely.thank so to kind of feel that
way about celebrities you know when
people talk [ __ ] about celebrities like
I met him he's such an [ __ ] I'm like
you don't know what [ __ ] day the
other day I was not having a good day
and I was very like not not with it and
this girl like she stopped to let my car
go but she stopped that I was taught to
let her go when I was on an issue like
email in Jerusalem I was still out yeah
or like you have people like how are you
yeah I smile at like obese girls at the
gym
yeah that's after all been I know I need
to erase everything
oh no after all the beautiful point
you've made in images I have to the it
gets uncomfortable to be good for too
long smiles Oh mommy have you ever like
at Starbucks like wherever like people
will be like oh here's your drink thank
you so much have a great day they look
like yeah oh my gosh thank you no one
say this baby was anything like if you
go to a clothing store and they're like
how are you that everybody's been ruined
normally but I'm like if you say like
what our shows are like I do me what
everything is that one thing just mean
like yeah I'm doing great thank you as I
how many people go through that you're
making them coffee or you know customer
convene as a customer service person or
whatever and like no intention to you
know appreciate your people just want to
be appreciated I think what helps you in
my situations like that is if you if
they have a name tag or if you learn
their name Thank You Jen or whatever
when you say when you say their name I
feel like that makes them feel a lot
more valid I already did all of us
almost cover me higher this is the you
know Terry on accent hi Terry
yeah I'm homeless bad question my bank
accounts negative right now what the
hell I'm saying I have a lot of money in
my everyday care what it is not showing
up today
I've been reading too secretive it tells
me that none of those blood pudding in a
particular series is working we have
love and hate are beasts and the one
that grows is the one you feed
oh I think I did yeah I learned from a
book that said in the whole like the
whole chapter I read of this of this
book was talking about how every emotion
essentially every emotion comes down to
love or fear yeah everything I got the
girl book to look for Edna
yeah and like hate would go under the
category of fear yeah and whatever one
you feed I feel like you'll attract no
matter no matter what it is whether you
love or fear whatever one you're most in
tune with you're going to attract so
it's important to acknowledge these
things oh man
we can there be such as serious good
there be a moment on my hair can ruin
every fear is like my everything my
false evidence appearing real
yeah oh I ran out look big magic by it
was a good one yeah where she said
there's always going to be there like
you can't live we tried so hard to like
get rid of
it was always gonna be here so you got
to be like I'm putting you in the
backseat you're always going to be there
thanks for trying to protect me I'm not
going to listen to you and I'm keep
going yeah it's like be afraid do it
anyway yeah might as well just give it a
shot I've also heard fear acronym forget
everything and run not run away run I
mean just do it your and judgment are
there to like healthy like there like if
you're walking down their alley and you
get scared back what's supposed to me
and then we've taken it and made so much
more like you know here I love you I'm
scared oh you're gonna hurt me I'm
scared oh I can't do this cuz I'd like
your fears are I feel like the best way
to deal with fear or like nervousness or
anything is its first technology just a
minute and then I do it yeah otherwise
it'll containing you and I coming up and
it's going to overtake somehow and [ __ ]
up everything alright great pub ain't
quite that for a couple of this guys
poems he does do some great poetry spree
beautiful hot piece of ass kicking me
out both scream we went on a [ __ ]
free for you hope you enjoyed the video
subscribe to the real reject check out
more SJ click on videos how to use of
Morgan that Morgan hand this is Ashley
ender how to use the morning and
actually a video line will be up there
soon yeah how to Blanc make it right we
can't Morgan my buddy white hand to you
Morgan on Instagram and Ashley ed nur on
Instagram would be pasty [ __ ]